now the issue of horse meat eating
horses has been taboo for almost all of
American history and with good reason
but recently Congress has considered
changing US law to revive the American
horse slaughter industry here's what
horse meat advocate Dave Duquette had to
say about it watch
okay thanks often come on thanks tucker
thanks for having me on so this as you
well know strikes a lot of people
particularly in cities as horrifying why
is it a good idea it's it's mainly a
welfare issue tucker it's the welfare of
horses in the horse world is that it's
gone downhill ever since and when you
have something that doesn't have any
value at all which is what the unwanted
horse is they end up getting shipped to
Canada or Mexico and they just they're
not worth anything right we have that
problem with a lot of domesticated
animals certainly with cats and dogs and
unfortunately we we euthanize a lot of
them that's really sad but we don't eat
them because it feels like it's crossing
the line because we're so close to them
why our horse is different horses are
considered livestock in every state in
the Union and right there are on average
a thousand pound animal and as far as
euthanizing them you start euthanizing
the 150,000 unwanted horses a year and
you're talking about millions of pounds
of toxic waste
oh so it's a question of disposing it
and who would eat it well we have quite
a market actually when in 2011 when the
riders came off the appropriations bill
my name was all over it because I was
advocating for it uh-huh and the Thar
got I was contacted by the Tongan
communities there was one meat buyer in
the south of in Florida that said he had
2.3 million Hispanics down there that
would eat it every day if they could get
it I guess I mean the other groups right
but I mean America has always been
distinct in that we don't eat it and the
French do and it's it I mean to be
totally blunt with you it's been for
more than a century kind of a point of
pride a braggy
point that you know you eat horses and
we don't doesn't this kind of put us at
the level of the French if we start
doing it that's kind of a total misnomer
or however you want to put that the over
50% of the world's countries eat horse
meat every day if you go around Europe
yeah the whole European Union you'll
find more traditional horse meat recipes
than you will any other type of meat the
from the Chinese the Mongolians the
Japanese that's all the Indonesian
countries Africa just about every
country in Africa if they can get a hold
of horse meat that they'll eat it South
America Mexico if you've eaten tacos on
the beach in Cabo you've eaten some
horse meat until 1985 there was horse
meat was available on the menu at the
Harvard faculty club and the only reason
they quit doing it was because the new
chef the meat came to and flash-frozen
the new chef did not want to cook
anything that had been frozen that's the
only reason it went off and that was all
the way to 1985 we have a huge history
of horse meat consumption in the United
States and the humane society United
States will try to tell you that that's
not so well it is so I mean it doesn't
take very much googling and very much
looking around to find that we did
consume a lot of horse meat in the
United States I thought it was just
Lewis and Clark and an emergency in a
blizzard to the Donner Party or
something I had no again you're making
me rethink that vacation in Cabo